the news that divergent is gonna go to  television has that settled with you now  how do you feel about that in two  hundred years the greatest scientific  minds have lived here to test a theory  if we could rescue people from the toxic  environment and put them in a safe place  like Chicago perhaps they would heal it  and I'm one of those people you are the  only one yeah I mean it's deficits the  news it's the word on the street I  didn't sign up to do a television show  so I'm not sure that I will be a part of  that television show but out of respect  to the studio and to everyone involved I  don't think it's been finalized that  that's what they're doing so there could  have been things that are changed that  have changed that I don't know about  going